hello and welcome to this video playing
wish run this one I don't know all right
so let's play classical chess
put pawns in the center and now yeah
I've dabbled a little bit with the
Queens gambit accepted in recent times
but I have another line that I want to
give a try oh it just goes g3 okay I got
some additional options here now okay
let's see what he's up to
oops sorry for that okay didn't even
know that this is kind of possible okay
I got a message by my Google Calendar
that I should water my plants okay I
have that in my calendar to remind me
that I'm not letting those poor things
dry to death but I wasn't sure I wasn't
aware that I could get a message a
message here on my desktop about that
it's good to know that after this video
I should um should do that okay so I've
gotten a bit of a center control now the
interesting thing is here how the so I
get any counterplay him and probably
this yeah I expected that move hmm
so now do you take or what do you do
with black I don't know I don't know
this line I'm going to take my guess
you're taking with the pawn even maybe
no pawn takes with the idea to play a5
where this looks more natural but a bit
of an odd position quite an unusual but
I don't quite okay
this is this is interesting it's a way
to try to justify the plane
hmm okay um I have to check can also
take immediately I'm just going to take
me I don't know maybe I should have
checked
so check on b6 and na create for some
champion
Haruki Aidan's kinda well it's not not a
very useful tempo we just complete
development here and white is quite
active them the bishops look quite
active but he has a he has a wicked King
it's something that in the long run can
prove to be important so um just
castling no guess home yeah I would like
to play something like rook e8 bishop f8
that looks good
securing the King side I'm a little bit
concerned about those those bishops okay
so I guess he wants to be em yeah wants
to clear the e-file yep the bishop only
form oh great
Queen trade hmm right so I'm not sure
about that
do I have one the Queen trade it's not
bad don't think this is bad for me in
any way so
let's see we can get a bit of pressure
actually here I mean he has the bishop
on g2 of course but my bishops also have
a good range and they look towards the
Queen side it's not that easy to
determine what to do after a five okay
is out four nights e5
yeah
after 95 my ideas to take it play Bishop
d5 claim that this is about equal
you know I'm okay with the with the
rooks coming to the to the central files
I should be fine I'm not better or
anything's but but it should be an okay
position controlling those two files
must mean something
my knight needs some improvement but 95
to d3 as kind of a natural thing to do
well that's a bit hard to smoke I mean
I'm happy with this Andrew p5o head
would be five actually that's something
that that I should have looked at that
that wasn't so great it was like am
probably one time opportunity okay now I
can take on d4 play Knight III form the
slightly better ending I don't know if I
want to do that maybe maybe this one for
a little trickery
now I'm threatening this and I'm in a
much better version okay only got 11
seconds that's not good
yeah the trickery line wasn't that great
okay
but now night b5 is still it's still in
there in the mixer yeah yeah I'm not not
happy not happy I I was just having a
nice position and this rook rook b5
would have just won a pawn for nothing
was I was bad bad thing bad thing to
miss what a stupid game I really hate to
hate how I played this just let us just
let this happen when he didn't have
didn't do anything before that it was
just my own stupid plane
now you kind of hope for a miracle here
I mean why does not playing this well at
all but it's it's just so bad Ruka g6
for example was a lot stronger instead
of this
I is totally miss playing it not sure if
what's going on yeah I'm winning hear it
how is he stopping that he's not right
okay now he's threatening the promotion
and and then made okay so I have to go
here first and now he has to promote and
play look there
I'm not looking at this one please
[Music]
you know kind of it's kind of crazy that
I won the game but yeah I mean I'm just
I'm just very stupid yeah if I'm just
paying a little bit of attention I
played this and he just resigns they did
it win swings wins easily yeah it's not
it wins a pawn and it's just a terrible
position for white okay so let's have a
look there we cut this weird weird
opening here with a like a reverse
Greenfeld but white was never able to
take on c6 I played h6 this is kind of
normal in those situations to prevent
Bishop g5 okay he went Knight c3 Bishop
e6 therefore I have seen these ideas
it's not like I never seen it anyway um
I I took it yeah and they engineered it
is suggesting G takes well then this
this is a very complex position and very
unusual the the weird thing about this
is that white white has some really um
some glaring square weaknesses so like
this this and this is weakest but he's
very active d5 is under pressure he's
got this square as a it's a very
unbalanced kind of position very
difficult to handle interesting the
computer thinks white is very him I have
no clue really it's very complicated
okay so now he went before immediately
this this is probably okay for me no
not really
fearing this much queen h5f is given as
an idea yeah makes sense yep queen h5
maybe castling doesn't work here due to
the sacrifice yeah work so that
definitely is it's not going to sustain
for like okay so after Queen age five I
cannot cancel short computer once so
Castle queenside that's a tough one okay
so Queenie two castles Bishop g2 okay
eight looks very normal
Queen f2 I thought was surprising
somehow but okay I just I just captured
and then 8th is also kind of standard
yeah you want to provoke some weaknesses
should be three okay normal Bishop f6 is
given as an alternative I mean this this
approach here was rather simplistic but
I mean I must be fine here really
because of the central control but again
right is also not in trouble he should
just play something normal the engine
suggests Luke c2 here which is kind of a
non move but yeah I mean I would rather
be black on a stay because I have a
simpler ideas my my my pieces are active
and I have all month of those ideas him
but okay this just looked me five and he
can basically kick it in so now this one
and yeah Nancy voice it's just friggin
stupid 93 is still good you have course
home right not 93 actually this is just
a good good position I mean what I
initially wanted to do I was seeing this
idea but then realized that this is
actually nothing at all
yeah it's quite comparable to what we
got in the game it's just nothing and
then I've had let's be tricky now I'm
threatening this now if he would play
let's say b3 I can take here that was my
idea
sorry the other one I need to need to do
it with the other one so this this this
and then I'm winning the pawn that was
the idea but it's just silly because
he's got this and now I have yeah I have
nothing and here this is not very
harmonious all of a sudden a 95 is just
bad this is a bad move the resulting
ending is just bad I have to he has two
possible entry squares and it's just
like it sucks it just sucks it's just a
bad ending yeah many kind of I don't
know I didn't like it was ok up to this
point what he did but here for example
where was that there was one one bottom
position like he he he just played this
and then put the hook here and then you
win Oh automatically almost yeah you you
fix the g7 pawn you're controlling the
six ring yeah and then you push this
slowly that's it's simple win early and
yeah I'm kind of I have some hopes at
least so I know dd6 was was bad iam has
to go look g6 this is this is not clear
to me relief that it's not clear to me
like this
good yeah hmm tough tough to say the
engine wants to go King b7
this is really tough now to analyze I
mean what is important in general is
said who in this situation the pawn
count is not super important it's more
important like how quick the pawns are
because like two pawns and go quicker
than then three and one is quicker than
two we know that rule so yeah it's not
entirely clear the engine he had not a
very deep depth Gibbs Newton give zero
point six which is kind of nothing you
don't know what that means
d6 is not great a king c6 was so silly
actually I'm losing a tempo you will
play this happen anyway right okay the
Seven Kings is seven and now it's
probably okay arm but it's still
supposed to be a draw if you can believe
that the engine
age six I hope takes g5 yeah that might
say beard oil that that I can I can
believe with g5 I'm probably wow this is
this is funny yeah it's funny he has to
[Music]
do it like that and then he will home
again because I have to take care of the
H pawn as well I mean I can keep that
for the moment but once the H pawn runs
yeah I have to go here
h7 and then then we'll get the drawing
so that was a very clear way to draw h6
a - and it still should be a draw with
with this essentially the same thing
after again take care of the H point
myself and he will win all the ponds or
enough now this is a draw really
really this is a draw no that is a
winner and it's just a cut-off far too
far too much so the draw is rook a7 and
then taking it because I cannot I cannot
protect the b-pawn yeah and if I go
behind this pawn this is just about yeah
he's going back and then he then he just
wins it basically
okay so that was still a draw you played
h7 however after which I have to take
care of that okay
modes
yeah now I wasn't entirely sure I should
not go on the seventh rank I played kini
8 it's one of the two moves that win one
of the two most a twin king rooks is
seven is the other one yeah rooks is
seven this this wasn't entirely clear
maybe I can do this okay okay and then I
can start to start to run this okay okay
makini ADIS is probably right I just I
have to make sure that I get here and
get the King somehow cut off yeah that
that should be winning what is the best
best offensive try let's say he takes
just just to check then I'm going here
he approaches I go here and then I'm
cutting it off this this was the the the
basic principle and then you will win at
the end yeah with the probably with the
Lucena so that's and that's a fairly
easy one and so after King 80 is
probably lost he cannot prevent that
kingly five okay then the engine gives a
couple of mistakes here but it is it is
winning and now I'm just keeping both
pawn so it's going to be very easy just
play Ruby 7 push to be pawn yeah
interesting ending at the end very long
video thanks a lot for watching